come our celebrity watch Justin Bieber
into the action Justin Bieber takes in
the Toronto Maple Leaf six and final
playoff game with his younger brother
Jackson and Cara Delevingne
the popstar touched down in the city on
Sunday by private jet carrying with them
some custom-made jerseys which he later
Ward the game and when the competition
gets heated he lets his true fan boy out
posting this photo captioning it this
young team has so much potential let's
go all the way next year but with
Toronto's playoff loss last night Leafs
nation isn't exactly embracing Bieber
with open arms in the sports world
Bieber has been accused of being a bad
luck charm to the team that he throws
his support behind the heat the Black
Hawks and the Steelers have all been
victims of his curse with blame Bieber
becoming a hot trending topic on Twitter
back at 2014 and last night we see the
hashtag get an unfortunate resurrection
hours before the game Justin shares this
side-by-side photo the pic on the left
is of course his famous mug shot from
his DUI arrest three years ago and the
shot on the right is him today he
captions the before and after shot I
love this because it reminds me I'm not
exactly where I want to be but thank God
I'm not where I used to be the best is
yet to come do you believe it with
Bieber in good spirits he seemed to
enjoy his time with Carl last night the
model has been filming a movie in
Toronto called life in a year with Jaden
Smith here they are shooting a romantic
scene on the city streets with Cara
donning a pink wig for the role and with
an extended stay in Canada Cara
certainly is soaking up all of our
country's natural wonders that's her dad
yesterday at Niagara Falls
[Music]